[Música]
[Aplausos]
olha ai ai ai
[Música]
hoje é bem pouco tempo atrás eu alugo
oratório
sabe-se lá porque é mulher
[Música]
looooool e é isso
eu tenho é do senhor ao lado do pai
[Música]
porque hoje
segundo balanço do mar
[Música]
eu nem sei lá
ae o que revolta é o ó
[Música]
a acontecer porque não se olha o teu
irmão
[Música]
não me lembro a partida também era agora
como fui que é fiel como vinha colado no
mundo rock bem foi a partilhar com ele
[Música]
a linha conta com alguma mulher veio o
vi que o meu não é porque é conveniente
porque não voltar
[Música]
quem sabe eu possa sair hoje
e porquê
[Música]
jorge e e já bem fechar é uma forma de
proporcionar moça e ele que vá além do
roubo
o novo quadro legal
[Música]
uma coisa é criar um bairro ano bom e
vai jogar pro pessoal no livro eu acho
que você vai olhar
[Música]
meu pai quatro melhores equipes do ig
como o estádio é e sac ii
[Música]
[Aplausos]